what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today I was out
of town because this guy was gives
himself a little hitched yes yes and
this trailer actually came out at the
time of the ceremony so of course I
could not cover it but after an 18-hour
road trip I'm playing a little bit of
catch up here and I want her to watch
the open Heimer trailer I have become
death the destroyer of worlds I know a
little bit about Oppenheimer like kind
of the the general information the
Manhattan Project nuclear bombs all that
fun stuff but I'm excited that
Christopher Rollins take on this role I
hear Killian Murphy Chilean Murphy
Cillian Murphy everyone has a different
pronunciation for it comment below what
the correct pronunciation is for it
because I can never seem to remember I
think uh he's actually a wonderful
person to cast as Oppenheimer actually
so I'm excited for this man everything
about it sounds great John he is in
Colorado for a little while longer
enjoying himself and you know the rest
of the team mainly the rest of the team
meeting koi is uh he's got himself in
ear infection so just me right now but
hey let's get to it guys I'd also leave
a like that would be very much a pretty
leave a like you know how much I love it
when you leave a like
[Music]
whoa
wow
we imagine a future
and our imaginings horrifiers
they won't fear it
until they understand it
[Music]
they won't fear it until they understand
it they won't understand it
until they've used it
Theory will take you only so far
dare Happy Looks tortured
I don't know if we can be trusted
with such a weapon
that look he has in his eyes man
there's that classic Christopher Nolan
text
[Music]
Queen
ever
[Music]
trying to tell the truth
about what's Happening Here
[Music]
God damn
music is so the music you know in the
films so solid you know I really what
really struck me about performance of
Killian Murphy here silly Murphy
children for whatever I did remember
hearing that Oppenheimer was diagnosed
with schizophrenia and he refused to
believe uh that diagnosis like succumb
to that but you know knowing how I know
some people have different
interpretations about after he created
the nuclear bomb and of course that
famous quote of for he is quoting I have
become death to destroyer of worlds the
general takeaway from that was that
after he created it he was immediately
filled with that feeling of remorse uh
regret over what he has done it's almost
like he's like the real-life
Frankenstein to a certain extent
dedicates his whole life for years to
developing this then once he succeeds
and then when they they run the test I
believe was it in New Mexico when they
when they ran the test and you could see
like oh my god what have I created I've
created the ultimate Destroyer the
Ultimate Weapon and I bring up the
schizophrenia part of it because so much
of the performance seems to have that
tense paranoia just within his eyes
alone that was so striking and when you
do see that footage that that old
footage of Oppenheimer yeah he did have
that like wide-eyed look and the the
parts of this trailer that I thought
were really interesting were what it
does seem like the development of the
nuclear bomb the whole Manhattan Project
time which was quite a scrutinous
experience you know obviously heavily
heavily secretive there's also just
constant surveillance on the guy just
it's no no it's complete surrender of
privacy you even capture some of that
with with the amount of just like all
eyes on me and what am I doing and is
this the right voice and what I find
really fascinating about experiencing
just the trailer alone is while there's
that horror clearly that haunting
quality of this creation
that did take the lives of hundreds of
thousands of people it still had that
the the build up of of the Journey of
develop because you know obviously it
doesn't strike me as that Oppenheimer
was someone who was like this diabolical
you know evil guy genius dude who is
instantly like yeah I want to do this to
kill a bunch of people I want to do this
to destroy a bunch of lives you know it
seemed like to be capturing that while
there's that percolating Darkness it
seemed to constantly have this this
sense of wonder as well that that Nolan
Wonder touch which is probably what
Oppenheimer had in the development of
this or in the pursuit and curiosity of
discovering physics and all all that it
is all the life shears Journey leading
up to that moment of developing this and
being part of the Manhattan Project and
I thought that was all captured here in
quite an elegant way and there's
something that feels
wondrous ethereal and nightmarish as
your inner cutting you know inner
splicing all these all these different
moment of the flashes of the the nuclear
bomb like like the way it was at least
being demonstrated here felt like that
was part of how he's envisioning it like
maybe this you know no one's known to
play with time so maybe this won't play
out in such a linear way because you
have moments that are in black and white
in this trailer I didn't see the first
teaser for this I did see there were
some black and white images I didn't see
the teaser for this I wonder like is it
going to be dealing with cutting around
through time and and not in a non-linear
way of exploring how this all sort of
came to being developed yeah I mean I
thought that was uh quite a beautiful
trailer it's Christopher Nolan's first
time not first big movie without Warner
Brothers this is the first picture with
universal so I'm excited to see what
difference is if any that would
ultimately entail I like the classic
Nolan text he seems to constantly have
that text the part that has me a bit
concerned a a bit is I feel like Nolan's
films are generally better because he
tends to be uh one of the writers at
least but but his Inception co-written
by someone I I generally have the
association and I could be wrong I'm not
sure there's a fantastic null in film
that because I I either like or love his
films there's not about one of his
movies I straight up dislike but I I
tend to feel his films tend to hit a
little stronger when he has a co-writer
with it so that's my one one time and
one little bit of a concern there is
that it's it's just him credited a soul
Rider here so other than that I mean
this looks like a quite a fascinating
experience you know because he did
Dunkirk which was a historical piece
this is another historical biographical
piece as well as exploring a time in
human history development something this
innovations that that have still to this
day like it's scary man it's some scary
stuff you know there are active projects
or active campaigns you can donate to uh
that are all about out you know to help
put away like all nuclear bombs and just
that way it just doesn't exist like it
just shouldn't exist at all no one
should even have that as an option
because of the disaster so I wonder how
violent It'll like will they show the
Horrors of like Hiroshima and stuff what
will we see some of that like how how
much are we going to actually show or is
it all going to be solely focused on The
Haunting experience of Oppenheimer
Oppenheimer chilly and silly and Killian
I thought it was a great trailer though
I thought I thought it was excellent and
you know like a Nolan film on IMAX gets
me so excited gets me so excited like
just the visual experiencer it's rare
for me to experience a Nolan film for
the first time on on IMAX because I I
tend to be too late to buy the tickets I
do love the experience of first watching
it on a regular screen
and then going to IMAX and doing kind of
a comparison in the IMAX tends to just
be so immersive and sweeping that's why
I understood for the first time on IMAX
that was great yeah this looks awesome
awesome it feels like that great
Christopher Nolan touch and you know
like in terms of caption that paranoia
the guy did insomnia and Memento two
films were main characters had a
constant paranoia and uh I like it I
like it a lot this looks awesome guys
what'd you think about the trailer leave
your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe leave a like and uh hey I'll
talk with you all soon
thank you